fertile agricultural land used to be the
source of goning ins prosperity but
today the region's treasure is buried
three kilometres beneath the ground
natural gas the closely guarded Wells
are producing 50 billion cubic metres of
gas a year not a boss and her husband
live on top of this gold mine but the
riches beneath their feet have brought
nothing but trouble gas extraction is
causing the earth to shake and this is
an old farm - in the barn and they're
getting bigger you can even see outside
through this one about a Geiger the
whole farm is falling apart walls are
damaged the cracks over the doors are
getting bigger and we can't shut the
doors anymore
seismologists have registered 65
earthquakes here so far this year one of
them had a magnitude of 3.4 and
scientists predict the tremors could
soon hit magnitudes of 4 to 5 that
actually doesn't tell us a lot when it
comes to working out what's going to
happen you have to measure what affects
the movement of the earth are going to
have on the surface to see how the kinds
of houses you get around here will react
the scientists want to gather more data
before they issue recommendations and
that suits the gas drilling company just
fine we've known for a long time that
gas extraction and earthquakes are
connected now we know more about their
size but we have to wait for the studies
before speculating activists from the
local pressure group think owning an
earth movement however say that
scientists have gathered enough
information to act now
there's enough gas for the whole country
for years despite that they keep upping
production levels and that's just
because of the money tamago natural gas
extraction is channeling 12 billion
euros annually into state coffers over
the past few years production rates have
more than doubled almost every Dutch
household uses coning and gas for
cooking and heating and export contracts
have been signed for many years to come
so the state is hesitant to turn off the
taps even despite warnings from some
official sources that includes the
general inspector of the state mind
surveillance service which is also
responsible for gas extraction his
demands are not being met on the mess we
want the serious risks faced by people
of Groningen to be reduced to a
justifiable level that's only possible
in the short term if production is
reduced as quickly as possible
and as far as is realistically possible
to bring her so far the gas company has
limited itself to paying for
construction engineers to document the
cracks in houses and is promising to pay
for the damage Eric Shipton has an
appointment with Hank and Vova Emma camp
he says their case isn't all that
serious oaken all over Thailand well
this is an old crack here you can see
that by its width but the crack has
grown larger because of the quakes and
we're going to deal with it before it
gets worse
but the EMA comps aren't just worried
about the cracks they've spent a lot of
money on their home and have been trying
to sell it for five years now House of a
coked-out hill flare sales are bad
because of the earthquake so we'll have
to wait and see the mother's - ha
but a lot of people can't wait property
values are falling and more than 7,000
homeowners have registered damages
States man means more and more people
feel like they've been taken hostage in
their own a lot of them want to leave
because they're scared of the next quake
but they can't because their homes are
unsellable so they're trapped in an
earthquake zone with an uncertain future
Mata boss doesn't want to leave she
spent her entire life at the farm but
she's not sure the house can be saved by
slapping her she'll take care of us we
sleep above the cellar if you look at
how the beams are bent then I'm worried
that we'll end up in the cellar one day
doctors from some so nominator follow a
lot of people who live above the gas
field are worried that their safety is
being sacrificed for the money that it
brings
you